Це сувенір ще з того мого життя.
Цей прапор був символом ненависті до всього світу навколо.
Цей прапор відображав відчуття того,
що ви ненавидите нас отаких, а ми ненавидимо всіх вас.
Його демонстрація була маніфестом.
Мене звати Дмитро Різниченко. 37 років.
Журналіст за освітою, активіст, учасник Революції Гідності,
член дуже багатьох ультраправих,
праворадикальних і консервативних організацій -
до революції і після.
Головне, що треба для того, щоб стати ультраправим,
- це малопояснена, несвідома, але всепоглинаюча
ненависть до всього світу навколо.
Я прочитав "Бійцівський клуб" Чака Паланіка,
коли був студентом. Він обмалював широкими мазками
відчуття ненависті до світу.
Тобто ненависті до епохи, яка б вона там гарна не була.
Ненависті до людей, ненависті до всіх їх проявлень.
І навіть якщо ти живеш у ситому, спокійному,
ліберальному і забезпеченому західному суспільстві,
якщо ти ненавидиш,
то ти знайдеш, що там ненавидіти.
І плюс "Бійцівський клуб" показав безмежну хвилю,
море агресії,
яка тоді, студентом, здавалася виходом.
Я почав шлях насилля з бійцівських клубів,
тобто там, де ти приходиш до незнайомих людей,
які прийшли так само, тебе не знаючи, і ви б’єте один одного
просто тому, що у вас забагато агресії і треба
її кудись подіти. І знов-таки: на якомусь етапі
ти розумієш, що таке типу вбивання один одного
ні до чого, за великим рахунком, не веде,
крім того, що ви калічите один одного.
Тому починаєш шукати. Гітлер потрапив в руки.
Гітлер пояснив, кого треба ненавидіти,
більш конкретно й цілеспрямовано.
Праві ненавидять того, на кого їм вкажуть насправді.
Об’єкт ненависті - це таке змінне поняття.
Головне, яка книжка потрапить в руки людині,
яку пече ця ненависть зсередини.
Потрапить який-небудь ваххабіт-проповідник -
буде з нього радикальний мусульманин.
Якби він народився десь у кінці 60-х,
йому потрапив би який-небудь Сартр і радикальні ліваки -
став би червоним терористом.
Тут головне - ненавидіти світ, а чого саме
ненавидіти - ну, придумаємо по ходу.
Спочатку я захопився націоналістичними ідеями
ще у 2005 році, здається. Тобто одразу
по Помаранчевій революції. Вступив в УНСО, яке
ще було тоді тільки відкрилося маленьке в Дніпропетровську, 2006-го.
Потім переїхав у Київ, вступив у "Братство" Корчинського,
потім із Братства вступив у С14.
Шукав
об’єкт своєї ненависті і прикладення до нього.
Бо там могли пояснити, що зі мною відбувається,
зі своєї точки зору, і сказати, хто в цьому винен.
Жиди, москалі, геї, хто там ще, феміністки, ліберали,
забудовники.
Тобто кожна організація мала свою специфіку,
але, по суті, всі вони одні й ті самі були - маргінальні і антисуспільні.
Це ж недарма кажуть, що патріотизм -
останній прихисток негідника.
Бо можна бути патріотом, а можна бути негідником
і водночас патріотом, і негіднику-патріоту багато чого прощають.
Пам’ятаю, після Майдану я зустрів одного хлопця.
Я знав, що він комуніст, він лівий активіст
за переконаннями. І я як би знав, що ліві активісти -
це наші вороги. Я його зустрів, побачив:
"О, комуніст!" - і без зайвих слів почав його гамселити.
А потім з’ясував, що цей хлопець -
він активіст Майдану був,
тобто ми з ним, за великим рахунком, билися з одного боку,
він був медиком і, цілком можливо, він би мене і витягав.
За цей випадок, чесно кажучи, соромно.
Я потім дуже сильно вибачався перед ним
і підозрюю, що він досі мене не вибачив.
Я теж колись думав, що ультраправі -
то була рушійна сила Революції Гідності,
бо це приємно так думати. Насправді
більшість сотень, які там були - це були звичайні собі хлопці.
І війна показала потім. Знову ж таки, для мене
це відкриття було. Я жив із відчуттям, що ми тут
єдині воїни і кшатрії, ми тут єдині можемо битися
за країну, що від нас тут все залежить.
Я потрапив на фронт добровольцем і побачив
навколо себе дуже різних хлопців.
Перебуваючи в цій субкультурній бульбашці,
не виходячи з неї, я навіть не уявляв, що такі є.
А вони є. І вони, виявляється, і б’ються
не гірше за нас. І геройствують не гірше, а то й
ще краще. Я ще й з’ясував, що величезна кількість
ультраправих, навпаки,
всцялися з переляку і навіть на фронт не поїхали.
З ультраправого руху я вийшов поступово.
Тобто переломний момент
був у місті Іловайськ
в серпні 2014 року,
коли уже майже в оточенні і під страшним обстрілом
довелося дещо усвідомити, чого раніше не усвідомлював.
Тобто що всі ці ігри, в які ми гралися десятиліттями,
жорстокі ігри, які нам давали відчуття сенсу,
вони загалом закінчуються тим, що людей
закопують бульдозерами і на тому й про них забувають.
Тобто нічого ні святого, ні вічного у цьому немає.
У мене якраз донька старша мала йти в перший клас.
Я дуже хотів потрапити на перший дзвоник до доньки,
а натомість ми сиділи на війні і здавалося,
що нам там хана.
Я не думав про нацизм, я не думав про націоналізм,
я не думав про патріотизм, я про доньок весь час думав.
Я вернувся пораненим. Рука прострелена,
все пафосно.
І от на мітингу ми стоїмо і всі горлають гасло:
"Україна понад усе".
Це ж загальна тема - "Über alles", тобто
наша ідея понад усе, вона вища за все.
А я замовк тоді, бо я згадував, що я думав тоді
про доньок. І думаю: ну що значить "понад усе" -
понад усе й понад навіть за доньок?
А я тільки що відчував, що ні.
Що є речі, важливіші навіть за Україну -
сім’я, діти,
гуманність, людяність якась. Виявляється,
є речі важливі. І я проковтнув це гасло,
так і не зміг його сказати. І от я думаю,
що з цього моменту почалось яке-не-яке усвідомлення.
А потім потроху вже з точки зору,
що це не абсолютна система, ти починаєш
розглядати різні питання, відношення до того чи іншого -
до ЛГБТ, до соціальної справедливості, до віри, до багато чого.
Ти починаєш переосмислювати все,
починаєш читати альтернативну інформацію,
тобто тобі нарешті потрапляють в руки книжки,
які раніше ти ніколи не брав. І отак потроху-потроху
я відмовлявся від одного постулату, іншого, третього, четвертого, п’ятого.
Раніше я любив війну як таку.
Тепер я усвідомлюю, що війна - це велика трагедія
і по можливості її треба уникати, як тільки можна.
Але іноді бувають ситуації, коли тобі не лишають вибору.
Якби Україна вела загарбницьку війну або навіть
підкорювала якусь бунтівну провінцію, я був би
різко проти. Тобто нам вистачить тої землі,
яку нам Бог дав, і зайвої точно не треба.
Але коли проти нас Росія, яка прийшла на нашу землю
і відбирає нашу землю -
ну добре, це всього-на-всього земля,
але ж Росія несе з собою свій російський порядок,
в якому нема місця не те що свободі...
Я зараз дуже ціную свободу.
Свободу для всіх -
для тих самих ЛГБТ,
для ліваків, для всіх.
Щоб люди мали можливість висловитись.
Для своїх колишніх побратимів я, звісно, зрадник.
Я розумію їх розпач. Це ж на тому, що
"ми, не дивлячись на наше жалюгідне суспільне становище,
все одно найкращі воїни і найкращі люди", -
на цьому ж тримається єдність і фундамент
всіх цих організацій. А якщо хтось несподівано каже:
"Знаєте що, хлопці, ви тут насправді невдахи
і я теж невдаха і давайте з цим якось закінчувати,
бо, здається, не тим ми займались",
то як би все життя і вся біографія -
насправді небезпечні, реально страшні біографії,
тюремні строки навіть - все це було дарма?
Звісно, це викликало у них величезну агресію.
Тому на мене було кілька нападів,
зеленкою очі залили, барбоси-хулігани.
Ось у мене шрам від кастета досі тут маленький.
Людей, які повністю розчарувалися в ультраправих ідеалах,
багато, як я потім з’ясував.
Я думав, що я один такий. Багато насправді.
Але дехто з них тихенько просто відійшов в сторону,
зайнявся своїми справами і намагається
налаштувати своє життя, зібрати його з уламків.
А ще дуже багато людей продовжують перебувати
в ультраправому русі, в ультраправому середовищі,
не сваряться з колишніми побратимами,
бо в них
нема нічого іншого, крім цього руху.
В Україні подібних організацій, які допомогли б
ультраправим реабілітуватися і вийти, немає.
Але це потрібно, бо, як я вже сказав,
це не просто переконання. Це переконання, які
визначають всі аспекти і грані твого життя.
Це секта, за великим рахунком, і вийти з секти
означає відмовитися від усього свого соціального набутку,
який у тебе взагалі є.
Треба нову дівчину, нових друзів,
нову роботу, нове місце життя, бо знайдуть же ж.
Тобто все треба нове. Ну звідки це взяти?
Таких людей треба реабілітувати системно,
як і працюють із сектантами в певних країнах.
Мені потрібна була системність якась і я потім
досить довго шукав і знайшов нарешті.
Я вступив до міжнародного інституту психоаналізу,
і там тепер уже я системно вивчаю, отримую другий диплом.
Вже рік майже.
І мені надзвичайно подобається.
Я зараз пишу книжку - інтенсивно надзвичайно,
але, блін, дуже повільно, бо доводиться дуже багато
знань запресовувати в маленькі цеглинки абзаців.
Книжку я назвав "Фанатик".
Вона, власне про явище фанатиків, про явище
ідеології ненависті і людей, які віддають їм всього себе.
У першу чергу вона має допомогти особисто мені.
Я хочу описати і усвідомити весь цей шлях.
Звідти й до нормального людського співіснування.
Але я сподіваюсь, що люди, які вже усвідомили,
що з ультраправою ідеєю, або там з радикальним ісламом,
або з будь-якою іншою ідеологією ненависті щось не так,
і які не бачать виходу - я знаю таких, їх вистачає, -
їм буде легше, якщо вони будуть знати,
що хтось уже цей шлях пройшов і цей шлях освітив.
І якщо її прочитати, то можна було б побачити його.
Звісно, вони виходитимуть самі.
Але такий дороговказ, мені здається, буде суспільно корисним.